hi guys I have some good news today well
I think it's pretty good news from this
point onward I'm probably going to be
able to no lie for all the codes that
good three against oh [ __ ] yeah
basically I am going to have my last
exam in this Tuesday and yeah I kind of
care about that so I'm kind of studying
for that but then again it's my last
exam and I don't really have anything
else yet so so in vacation is kind of
already started so this weekend I was
like yeah [ __ ] it I'm just going to
stream lots and lots of rollercoaster
going through so I did that actually I
might as well actually stream
rollercoaster could three in a bit now
though I probably shouldn't say that in
a video because it's going to be
uploaded later but you know I'm not
professional about this but yeah anyway
what I wanted to do here was to get the
Main Street right and there were
actually many people saying why are you
not building rollercoasters that needs
to happen to well I just felt like
building the Main Street first and the
first thing that I did have to do with
the path works and as you may be able to
see or as you're going to see in a quite
a bit now is that this actually took
quite a bit of messing around and
changed changing the colors to brown and
then changing them back again and then
realizing that I wanted different
texture and stuff like that and in
hindsight I really shouldn't should have
just looked at that
after that I finished the entire thing
because it's really hard to judge things
when it's not completely finished yet
and I should probably do that with paths
as well but to be very honest when I
just make these paths the way I'm
looking at it right now it doesn't
really look too great but in the end
it's going to be worth it's definitely
going to work but you'll see that in a
bits because like I said I've been
pretty much in no lifing rollercoaster
game 3 and I think I haven't even talked
about the good news yet
damn I'm such a digressive terrible
things in my commentary yeah mainly the
reason for that is the fact that like I
said I have summer vacation and I'll be
able to know like [ __ ] and that means
that I am going to no live rollercoaster
in 3 at least that's the way I feel
about it right now
also I messed up on these paths terribly
I had no idea what the inside and the
outside of paths would but yeah that's
that's that's not what I should be
talking about what I should be talking
about is the fact that I have been
playing roller coaster good three no
life and that means that I have pretty
much a lifetime supply of time lapses
right now and as I am speaking
the Main Street is actually almost
finished it's just a couple of buildings
that still need to be built but we're
almost moving on to the rest of the park
that being said the Main Street will
take about five let's play episodes and
possibly quite a bit more because I want
to be perfectionistic about this park
and it's probably not going to result in
the best time-lapses ever it's going to
be quite a pain actually to go through
all those time lapses with all that
experimentation and things but yeah one
of the issues that I had with rose
gardens was that it was focused on the
time-lapse recording and even though the
videos of course are quite an important
point I actually make these videos
because I enjoyed playing the game and I
enjoyed building this bike and I just so
happen to record it and that's also the
kind of idea that I went into this bike
with is just to do whatever I felt like
doing and just completely ignore the
fact that I was recording and that this
was going to be turned into a time-lapse
and the good part about this is that one
issue that I had with rose gardens was
the fact that you know sometimes it was
focused on time lapses rather on the
final result and it just turned into
nice time lapses but sometimes the
result wouldn't be all that great and I
usually didn't stick around to certain
areas to experiment with new sets and
experiment with new ideas and generally
just fiddle about with certain things
and so I felt happy about them and just
kept them the way they are because I
felt like it would be a waste of time
lapses and I'm going to disregard that
and just work on things regardless of
whether it should be a good recording or
not because I want to work towards a
final result rather than good time
lapses so yeah I'm sorry on my behalf of
why if these time lapses turn into
terrible things and if I procrastinate
things in the streams or mess up things
or start experimenting with stuff that I
really shouldn't do that the time lapses
turn out to be weird somehow it is about
the final results that I really want to
get done and so far actually I liked it
more than the past two parks that I've
built so far but I shouldn't reveal to
reveal too many things but yeah I'm
going to be releasing quite a bit of
video
those stuff though possibly every two
days kind of went to release one video
every two days at least for their next
upcoming period and if I do miss out on
that I'm probably going to release like
two videos in one day or whatever to
make it up but I just want to get as
much as I can because I'm playing this
game so much and if I don't start
commentating over things and start
rendering and editing things then I'm
going to have more videos on my PC then
I applied drive space for and that
doesn't even exist so I can't even
record anymore if I keep up the speed of
streaming and stuff like that so I might
actually be forced to work on other
things just because I don't have any
space on my computer left anymore yeah
but that's pretty much the kinds of
things that I've been dealing with that
was a terrible stream of consciousness
I'm very sorry for if that was very
confusing I am terrible at speaking in a
coherent way if I actually really want
to do it it's terrible anyway this is
just some of the last path works this is
kind of the last thing that I wanted to
get done and this is going to be the
entire main street it's not going to be
longer it's not going to be wider this
is it and this is going to be the area
where I'll have the buildings as well so
that is pretty small but then again I
want to keep this park to not be too big
I don't want to blow it up as much as
Disney blows up this stuff the kind of
thing that I want to go for and this is
actually a cool thing that I've heard
about in the in the comment sections and
in the streams and everywhere basically
is I want to go through something Disney
ish but then then again we all know how
Disney likes to be really big and stuff
like that and rollercoaster second three
doesn't appreciate that so I'm going to
make it slightly smaller than the
average Disney park and I also want to
get some influences from example Europa
Park in there actually you rope a Park
is a pretty big influence on this park
so the thing that I want to do is I want
to get some good big roller coasters in
this park as well kind of like Europa
Park or at least one of them at least
one of them and very likely some kind of
bien ma B and M input would be a cool
idea maybe a flyer but I'm not really
sure and somebody posted a winged rider
as well so yeah I'm kind of just coin
tossing between those three things you
can't even coin toss
doing three things but you get what I
mean but I the time that I start
building that thing I'm just going to go
with whatever it fits the theme that I
would have best or whatever works best
in the parkour is simply whenever I feel
like maybe I'll do all of them but
probably not nuts quite a bit quite a
lot of kosis in just one Pike and anyway
this is the first building should I talk
about this building I feel like I should
because I always feel like I have some
kind of relationship with this building
it's just a building that I find so cute
whenever I look at it I just feel like I
nice building this is look at that
little fellow I know that's really
stupid to say but it's it's just that
one building that first building in
which I was kind of messing around and
just looking at the new sets and I just
download Main Street seven and eight I
never used to have those sets I have no
idea why I've had all of the other main
streets for years now but I haven't had
the other ones so I decided to get those
two and I was like hmm this is actually
pretty good
we're actually some pieces in there
they've always wanted so all of the
complaining about shyguys Main Street by
the way is now undone because I
completely forgot about the fact that
seven and eight also exists as sets but
yeah the reason why I like this building
a lot is because it was that first test
building it was that small test to see
if the Main Street would actually work
with this kind of path work over here
and the entrance and this building
pretty much proved to me that yes it
does kind of work and I like the shape
and the colors though honestly you can
just chalk that up to random luck I
guess I really didn't know to what I was
doing like I said it was just a bit of
an experiment and to see where I wanted
to be heading and I just wanted to get
that blue colored wall over there
because that was something that you know
many European countries have in some of
their buildings and I wanted to get a
red roof because that's the same same
kind of thing and then it just turned
out that that worked so well with the
Main Street set like usually you don't
really want to mix blue and red and
buildings but this very lights of washed
out kind of blue works surprisingly well
with a red dye color so I am really
happy about this building a high site
and it's I say that too many times but
yeah I'm pretty happy about this
building
and it pretty much proved to me that
this main street might actually work out
and in the pretty near future I guess
you can judge if it really works
yourself but I'm pretty happy with it so
far and this is really the only building
along with some other random kind of
Transylvanian building that I'll be
building in this episode and in the next
episode I'll be focusing on some other
buildings as well generally most of the
time that's going to be spent in the
next five episodes is just going to be
buildings on the Main Street because you
know you have to get all those details
done but also I wanted I want every
building to have some kind of individual
quality that the other buildings don't
have so I don't want to use the same
sets on just the same buildings all over
the Main Street also I was pretty happy
about this building about the fact that
the Western the station jim's Western
things too I think that's the name of it
whatever it was it was his Western set
worked out really well on those arches
and I I was pretty lucky to just
randomly think of the fact that those
things had arches and that they might
work and that they actually did work so
yeah I'm pretty damn happy about that
building probably should stop talking
about that but it raised my expectations
for the rest of the Main Street and then
I didn't meet them because all of the
other buildings didn't really work out
as well as that first one but I guess
you'll see that or in the next episode
so I'll see you then thanks for